estar es para ti tales como tú has dicho
largas filas han sido la principal
preocupación durante la apertura de
todos los centros de votación sin
embargo el presidente del consejo
nacional electoral diana atamaint
informó hace pocas horas que el 100 por
ciento de las juntas receptoras del voto
ya se encuentran abiertas en este país
lo que quiere decir que en ecuador ya
han votado 17 7 por ciento de los
electores dentro del padrón electoral de
una condena de 13 millones de votantes
habilitados para ejercer el derecho al
voto y precisamente la preocupación ha
sido las largas filas durante este
informe que ofrecía los consejeros del
órgano comicial exhortaban inclusive a
los distintos representantes de estos
centros de votación a flexibilizar un
poco las medidas porque las personas
tienen temor luego que el tiempo que se
toman el distanciamiento social para
ingresar a los centros de votación y de
igual tienen temor de que no puedan
ejercer el derecho al voto más sin
embargo el consejero del órgano comicial
el señor verdesoto ha dicho que la
participación es alta es buena y podría
inclusive terminar con una participación
superior a los regular en este país
el jugador se encuentra en medio de la
pandemia que ha grabado la fuerte crisis
económica y ha llevado al país a un
mayor endeudamiento cuáles son los
principales retos que enfrentará el
nuevo presidente
los principales retos que enfrentará el
ecuador será crear mecanismo de ayuda de
emergencia para poder recuperar la
economía de los ecuatorianos inmersa en
una gran deuda pérdida de empleo un gran
déficit fiscal por el cual los
candidatos a propuesta inclusive la
reducción tributaria la generación de
empleo de igual forma poder superar este
gran déficit fiscal de igual forma
también cambiar la matriz productiva
principalmente extractivista petrolera
en el ecuador para impulsar así otros
sectores de producción con lo cual y de
igual forma la necesidad de
financiamiento que este país este año
tendrá 7 mil 900 millones de dólares